four sky news the pollsters ipsos mori
spoke this week between monday and
wednesday to 2000
people and uh
one in three of those people said they
found it either difficult or very
difficult
to pay
their bill but if we look in more detail
at some of the numbers i think this
masks the scale of the problem for some
groups first look at the left of your
screen there households with children 37
are having difficulty paying what is due
and then to the right of the screen
household income at the top
those on lower incomes at the bottom
higher incomes perhaps no huge surprise
that people on lower incomes are
struggling most but also i think it's
interesting that one in four middle
income households say they are having
difficulty paying their bills that
perhaps suggests that politicians can't
target purely those who are on the
poverty line but it is such a broad
problem they'll need to talk about
wider perhaps even universal ways of
tackling this so how are different
people responding
uh in our research by ipsos mori almost
one in three
overall said they had used savings to
pay their
bill one in five so they set up a
payment plan with their supplier one in
seven had borrowed money to settle their
energy bills and a similar number asked
their supplier to accept a reduced
payment again this shows just how much
trouble some people are having even
before the expected eighty percent
increase this
eight percent increase this crisis is
just a beginning finally
who is ultimately gonna have to tackle
this the next prime minister from our
research uh asking people involved the
lady most likely to the next prime
minister of course this trust
uh
is uh only on 28
in terms of
people trusting her to give a great a
deal or a fair amount to tackle this
crisis she is behind as you can see
the incumbent behind the person who's
running against russia sunak and behind
sakir sama the labour lead
it shows that at this stage liz trust
doesn't have a huge amount of uh public
confidence and let's be honest here
whoever is the next prime minister the
polls suggest is going to be liz trust
they're going to face one enormous
crisis they will either have a very
short honeymoon or none at all and they
are likely to have to make some pretty
serious expensive decisions of how to
deal with this and support people and of
course you also got to realize that an
election isn't that
far away there'll have to be a point
where the new
prime minister tries to deal with this
issue anna and then pivots to some sort
of
election uh campaign footing and of
course if liz trusts or roshunak do lose
the next election they will be the
shortest
serving prime minister for almost 70
years it is not as some of their own
colleagues admit
a job that many would want to take on at
this time